Elisabeth borne va proposer au syndicat
de les recevoir en début de semaine
prochaine est-ce qu'il faut mettre cette
loi ce projet de loi sur pause Marina
Ferrari c'est ce que demande le modèle
si j'ai bien compris alors c'est pas
tout à fait ce que demande le modèle en
fait que demande le modèle alors
composant important de la majorité je le
rappelle oui lorsque demande le modèle
c'est très clair nous avons entendu la
proposition de dialogue de Laurent
Berger qui a été donc d'hier matin et
nous avons souhaité rétablir le dialogue
a fait la même proposition je crois que
c'est important de se remettre autour de
la table pour discuter autour de ce
texte ça faisait plusieurs mois
maintenant qu'il y avait pas eu ce
dialogue donc c'était le souhait du
MoDem que cette main tendue soit saisi
moi je me réjouis aujourd'hui que la
première ministre les saisies en
proposant à nouveau une rencontre à
l'intersyndical je crois que c'était
important après pour nous l'idée ça
n'est pas de remettre en cause le texte
moi je l'ai défendu en commission des
finances je vais pas me dédier
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est un texte
qui est nécessaire pour l'équilibre de
notre système de en revanche il y a des
dispositions dans le texte notamment une
clause de revoyure qui est un peu passée
sur les radars mais sur laquelle il me
semble qu'il faudra qu'on travaille
notamment puisqu'à horizon 2027 vous
savez c'est l'horizon que nous avons
fixé dans cette clause de revoyure si
des paramètres ont évolué alors on
pourra rediscuter et je crois que c'est
important aujourd'hui de reprendre le
dialogue c'est ce que nous avons voulu
défendre et la première ministre nous a
entendu mais en fait que peut dire la
première ministre parce que là je
n'étais pas politique fiction je laisse
la première ministre propre enfin
responsable de vous alors
qu'aimeriez-vous qu'elles disent
aujourd'hui au syndicat moi j'aimerais
ceux qui iront moi j'aimerais que le
dialogue se reprenne avec la totalité de
l'intersyndicale et et Monsieur
représentant de la CGT nous dira la
position aujourd'hui de la CGT voilà je
crois qu'on a encore des choses à
traiter autour de ce texte on a la
question de l'emploi des seniors qui est
qui est extrêmement importante l'égalité
salarial homme femme enfin la pénibilité
demain les carrières longues puisqu'on a
vu qu'il y avait des des soucis sur les
carrières longues tout cela il y a des
dispositifs qui sont dans le texte qui
parfois peut être ont été mal expliqué
je prends ma part de responsabilité dans
la présentation que nous avons pu faire
de la réforme mais je crois que nous
avons des choses à discuter pour
l'avenir qui sont très important sur ce
que dit Monsieur parce que c'est
important moi ce matin j'étais en ligne
avec un commerçant artisan de Savoie qui
est hôtelier restaurateur et qui me
disait que c'est réservations
s'annulaient les unes après les autres
du fait des mouvements de grève et que
ben il était aujourd'hui
issu déjà en plus la crise énergétique
donc il est dans une difficulté
économique majeure aujourd'hui c'est
dépend de notre économie qui sont quand
même menacées par ces mouvements sociaux
donc je crois qu'à un moment il faut
aussi qu'on trouve une phase
d'apaisement pour que l'on puisse
justement continuer à soutenir notre
économie c'est extrêmement important je
voudrais revenir sur l'idée tout à
l'heure de Monsieur on évoque une pause
mais de fait vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre préambule il y a une pause en ce
moment puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel rendra son avis le 21
avril vous l'avez rappelé donc mettons à
profit
voilà avant le 21 avril pour discuter
ensemble et pour régler les points qui
aujourd'hui mérite toute notre attention
vous vous les avez rappelé je sens la
clause de Revoy
enfin la clause en 2027 qu'elle a à quel
âge serons-nous pour la retraite à 63
ans et trois mois donc moi je pense que
c'est pas un gadget réforme Touraine
voilà absolument avec l'accélération de
la réforme Touraine donc il faut
discuter il faut voir les paramètres je
vous rappelle que 100000 emplois
seigneurs de plus c'est un milliard de
recettes supplémentaires donc on a des
vrais enjeux à travailler ensemble et
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse se mettre
autour de la table pour les travailler
seniors supplémentaires c'est vrai que
on remplit les quais Marina Ferrari oui
alors moi je voudrais revenir sur sur
plusieurs choses d'abord moi je ne Dénia
absolument pas le droit de grève il est
constitutionnel vous l'avez rappelé ce
que je remets en cause en revanche en ce
moment c'est les violences en marge des
cortèges et on voit bien les
problématiques auxquelles nous sommes
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui sur
le la légitimité de la loi moi je ne
partage pas votre sentiment ou alors on
part dans un débat philosophique comme
vous l'avez dit la loi aujourd'hui elle
a été effectivement votée bon il
l'instrument du 49-3 qui est tout à fait
légal et constitutionnel a été activée
je le dis je le dis librement moi
c'était pas c'était pas ce que j'aurais
souhaité j'aurais c'est qu'on aille
jusqu'au vote bon jusqu'au vote jusqu'au
vote le gouvernement on a décidé de
solutions
tout est-il que c'est un instrument qui
a été utilisé c'est la 100e fois qu'il
est utilisé sous la 5e République quand
même donc c'est pas non plus un
instrument qu'on a sorti du tout
gouvernement a sorti du chapeau comme ça
moi j'ai présenté le texte en commission
des finances pour avis il a été adopté
ensuite il a fait son chemin au
Parlement on a une obstruction
parlementaire dont tout le monde a
largement parlé il est parti au Sénat il
a été adopté en commission mixte
paritaire elle a été conclusive donc un
accord a été trouvé je tiens à le
rappeler parce que j'ai quand même
entendu certains collègues députés dire
les commissions experts c'est du
bidouillage alors qu'on en fait tout le
temps au Parlement sur toutes les lois
quasiment il y a des commissions de mix
paritaire donc à un moment je veux bien
mais on ne peut pas non plus raconter
n'importe quoi on est dans une démarche
législative qui certes peut heurter la
sensibilité de certains mais qui est
légal donc moi je m'inscris en faux par
rapport à ce qui était dit par rapport à
la légitimité du texte j'ajouterai que
les représentants au Parlement vous les
élus nous avons une légitimité qui est
celle des urnes nous avons été élus en
tout cas pour les députés au suffrage
direct par nos concitoyens voilà bon
après sur le dialogue moi sur le terrain
je rencontre toutes les organisations
syndicales et j'en ai encore rencontré
dernièrement le dialogue se passe bien
on arrive quand même à échanger sur le
fond du sujet sur la pénibilité du
travail sur on l'a évoque avant sur tous
les sujets sur lequel on doit aller
justement pour pérenniser notre système
et réussir le pari d'équilibrer ce
système interne et je souhaite que le
dialogue reprenne le plus vite possible
puis pour qu'on puisse avancer
et voilà pourquoi cette mesure sur le
fait d'avoir été dépossédé de la
possibilité de voter la loi je m'excuse
mais moi j'ai très mal vécu
l'obstruction parlementaire qui a été
faite pendant trois semaines au
Parlement parce que on a on a été au
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait son tweet
en disant êtes-vous t’empresser d'être
battu donc ralentissez les débats
excusez-moi mais moi je suis convaincu
alors on pourra jamais le trouver un
cadre restreint
nous avons été dépossédés aussi par
l'instruction parlementaires de certains
option moi je veux bien
du vote et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne voulait
pas du vote alors moi je vais vous dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a pas mis une limite d'âge à 64 ans
comme ça ça tient du chapeau on l'a mis
parce qu'on a un équilibre budgétaire à
tenir pour équilibrer
à horizon 2030
vous m'avez remonté les bretelles parce
que je vous ai coupé la parole tout à
l'heure alors il est au moins la
délicatesse de ne pas le faire
maintenant sur les 64 ans Monsieur c'est
une limite d'âge qu'on a fixé pour
équilibrer le système horizon 2030 et on
l'a pas fait ni pour vous berner ni pour
prendre pour des lapins de Sophie
nécessaire vous avez raison je partage
le fait qu'on a peut-être pas
suffisamment fait de pédagogie mais dans
le traitement médiatique qui est fait
aujourd'hui avec cette accélération il
était difficile d'aller dans le fond des
choses alors que le texte contient
beaucoup de de mesure correctives par
rapport aux inégalités de la vie vous
avez parlé du problème des petites
retraites il y a beaucoup de mesures sur
le sujet notamment pour les femmes alors
là où je vous rejoins c'est qu'il y a
une nécessité par rapport à cette
réforme concernant la dette publique
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire dans
l'hémicycle lors d'une intervention
puisque certains sur les bancs notamment
de l'extrême gauche nous accusait de
vouloir nous maintenir dans une
dépendance au marché financier or si on
ne fait rien à horizon 2030 vous le
savez la dette conjoncturelle sera de
150 milliards d'euros à laquelle il faut
ajouter aussi la dette structurelle du
système de retraite François bayroule a
bien démontré que lors de 40 millions
d'euros par an comment va financer cette
milliards
je vais vous demander donc si on doit à
horizon 2030 allez financer cette dette
sur les marchés financiers qui va
organiser une dépendance supplémentaire
et bah c'est ceux qui aujourd'hui ne
défendent pas cette retraite cette
réforme c'est ce que j'ai expliqué dans
l'hémicycle parce que on a tendance
toujours à avoir l'immédiateté mais pas
les conséquences aujourd'hui de notre
dépendance au marché financier et c'est
important de le rappeler cette question
c'est aussi une question morale
vis-à-vis des générations futures je
voulais juste répondre la réforme elle a
jamais été là pour financer autre chose
vous avez dit on a annoncé qu'elle était
là pour financer non absolument pas la
première chose ça a été très clair sur
le sujet pas 1 euro qui sera qui qui
sera issu de cette réforme ira autre
chose que le financement des retraites
deuxièmement les marchés financiers on
répond pas au marché financier
aujourd'hui on assure on vise assurer la
pérennité du système de retraite par
répartition et aussi on travaille pour
les générations futures parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas oublier que
c'est les cotisants actuels qui payent
les retraités d'aujourd'hui donc si on
veut que le système dure dans le temps
il va bien falloir qu'on équilibre les
choses et c'est ça la solution et en
même temps c'est une question de
souveraineté aussi et d'indépendance par
rapport au marché financier on peut pas
continuer à créer de la dette comme on
l'a fait ces dernières années et
monsieur a raison de ce point de vue
enfin l'Europe a rien à voir là dedans
on regarde les âges moyen dans les
différents pays européens on n'est pas
du tout aligné donc ça n'a rien à voir
et c'est pas un dictat de l'Europe
aujourd'hui sur le fond de réserve je
voudrais juste parler des fonds de
réserves des retraites pour faire j'ai
entendu beaucoup de choses notamment
venant à la fois de la CGT et à la fois
des mouvements plus à gauche dans
l'hémicier sur le fait d'aller prendre
l'argent qui est dans la cadette
aujourd'hui qui est une caisse l'un pour
le remboursement de la dette sociale
mais c'est oublier aussi que dans
l'histoire vous êtes historien monsieur
l'a rappelé dans la cadèse aujourd'hui
il y a des sommes qui proviennent des
caisses de retraite qui ont été
provisionnées sur l'empirement de caisse
de retraite donc c'est nier aussi
l'utilité de la cadette et toute dette
pour moi doit être remboursé c'est notre
responsabilité de rembourser la cadèse
et non pas de faire rouler la dette
comme on a pu l'entendre Parlement pour
moi c'est une forme d'irresponsabilité
budgétaire alors
Marina Ferrari merci moi je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Monsieur c'est
vrai qu'on a on a certainement eu un
problème de méthode depuis tout à
l'heure on en discute entre nous la loi
travail à venir
dans la revue venir avant peut-être
qu'on présente la réforme de retraite
bon c'est comme ça maintenant on va pas
pleurer sur les renversé cette loi
travail à venir va être extrêmement
importante sur les problématiques
absolument quel est l'auditeur dans son
intervention sur le fait que cette
réforme aujourd'hui des retraites soient
vécues comme quelque chose d'anti Macron
oui je partage ce sentiment moi quand je
suis en circonscription et que je
rencontre nos concitoyens j'ai pas du
tout lâché le terrain moi je suis pas du
genre à me planquer derrière mon petit
doigt ce qu'on dit c'est que très vite
on parle des retraites évidemment et
puis après on part sur autre chose on
part effectivement sur les conditions de
travail on part sur la problématique du
pouvoir d'achat qui est importante quand
j'entends des entreprises c'est leur
problématiques de recrutement etc donc
tout ça il va falloir qu'on travaille et
je suis désolé de vous le dire mais
c'est le dialogue social moi j'y crois
encore voilà le dialogue social
merci à